even though this is a prequel and it's a
different look and takes place in a
different time period it's it's just
kind of crazy to be able to to join
something that you've already been a fan
of and already been watching and to kind
of picture yourself in the world it's
very bizarre and it's really fun to
watch them shoot it too as a fan in the
script the character Lucky flickerman in
my opinion is very very very
underwritten and I said I think there's
just a ton of opportunity in any senior
in to have have much more stuff happy
Hunger Games Happy Hunger Games and um
remember when your tribute dies you're
out all right you know he's like there's
places in the script where we cut to him
but who knows exactly what the space
will be like in those exact moments and
so myself and Mike Lesley who wrote um
wrote this uh got together and we like
were just coming up with Yarns and yards
of lines and cooky things so we have
tons of other options for things within
scenes our apologies by the way for
saying the word lover on
television this is uh going out publicly
you know we can't say that something
about Jason is that he does something
new every take with what he says and
like the jokes that he makes and it has
us all in stitches every single time
it's always fresh it's always new it's
always within the character and the
confines of the time period that we're
in and the the situation that we're in
his behavior doesn't ever give in to the
fact that it might be a sad tragic thing
which makes his character so funny and
and gives that spark of joy that films
like this that have very dark situations
like we need that a little bit and so
it's a very it's very lifting really fun
process and in shooting we would
actually shoot out almost all the scenes
in the auditorium during the middle of
the games we'd usually shoot out you
know sort of all the characters watching
the games and you know snow and sanus
and whoever and anything and then we
would kind of finish our day with
through 3 hours left and just shoot
Jason and it would just be versions of
Jason doing and trying different things
and ripping and it was it was fun
because he's also you know he really is
for the most part the kind of comedy in
the movie he's the Le brings the levity
and a little bit of the relief to the
movie and so you want to make sure you
get some of that the creator of The
Hunger Games Dean High bottom Dean thank
you for all that you do and all that
you've done is the Afterparty still at
your place